lance lynn going to the mound
and he's making his 17th start looking
for his 10th win as era below 2.
the rest of the numbers spectacular this
is a former club of lancelin and he's
handled him pretty well
and luis arise left-handed batting
second baseman will dig in
two ground ball the whole right side
base in right field so a rise got jammed
but still
pulled it on the ground between mendig
and abreu so
a leadoff single for rise and some
early bluebirds once again for josh
donaldson donaldson is uh persona non
grata in this ballpark
after his comments during the last home
series donaldson to right goodwin back
on it to the warning track goodwin
runs it down deep in the corner brian
goodwin
an exceptional play for out number one
baseball karma attacks josh donaldson
there's trevor larnick who homered
against lance lynn
in that last start 12 days ago that's a
cutter for
trevor larnick and it's strike three so
lance lynn
still hasn't thrown a baseball out of
his own and two down
here comes nelson cruz 2-2 is bounced
toward right but mendic the second
baseman will cut it off in the grass and
he'll throw to first for the out
so lynn works around the lead off hit by
a rise
griffin jacks will be his sixth game and
his second start as you said
been a bit of a struggle you know his
slider is his swing and miss pitch but
he's also
giving up a lot of damage over 900
slugging percentage allowed so
he's gonna have to be able to locate
he's gonna have to mix and match tim
anderson leads it off
27 for his last 67. left side donaldson
has to cut it off and that's a smart
play but he threw it wide
that's too bad as it goes bouncing into
the dugout and tim's on his way to
second base
we talked about the karma got he gets
robbed of a double then he picks up an
air
tim's is second with nobody out here is
his switch
hitter johann monkatta he struck him out
swinging on a changeup
that's the 15th big league strikeout for
griffin jacks
anderson doesn't move off second base
one out one on now the reigning mvp jose
braves 3-2 pitch he
struck him out swinging stuck with the
slider kept it off the plate and debris
was not chasing that
early in the at-bat he did there
back-to-back strikeouts for jacks
two out anderson's still at second base
and now the batter is going to be brian
goodwin
swinging a missing down he goes a fist
pump from griffin jacks
as he strikes out moncada abreu and
goodwin
swinging the long goal against the
right-hander lance lynn
struck him out that's his first
strikeout in his last eight games
and it comes at the right hand of lance
lynn second strike got for lynn one down
no score bases emptiers kepler
there's a liner out in the deep right
playable and
caught by goodwin right in front of the
warning track
mikel sano and he drives this one in the
air out into deep
left center but again playable engel
makes a catch
a couple of hard hit falls for outs by
the twins in the second
adam angle leads off the bottom of the
second so a leadoff error in the first
inning got
tim on and then three straight
strikeouts from jacks topped up
foul ground playable for jeffers near
the white sox dugout nearly overran it
but caught it on the grass
and foul territory for the first out and
now the aforementioned first round
picked on bats
and they score the second inning ground
ball to third this is played by donald's
the second hop
and throws out vaughan for round number
two max has been very effective with his
basic two pitch combo that he likes
fastball and slider
real pitch is swinging a high fly ball
into left
playable for larnick in the sunshine now
charges calls and catches
round number three scoreless tie nick
gordon swings away
and a high fly to center drifting back
his angle he's under it he's got
it one pitch one out for lance lynn ryan
jefferson catcher
jeffers bounces it through the hole two
strikes put the ball in play and look
what happened
he's a board with one out that's their
second hit and it will bring up a rise
who let off the game with an o2 single
to left vaughn is underneath
number two here comes donaldson down and
away and he walks
get a bat there by donaldson first walk
issued by lance
off to donaldson we'll put two aboard
now for learning left-hand side andrew
vaughn has to race in tim is out there
and tim
anderson out of nowhere over the
shoulder
for round number three what a play to
get out of this
inning that could have been a lot of
trouble wow
i got to believe the second time through
they're going to get a better look
at jax right now for whatever reason
they're just not seeing the ball very
well he's making some good pitches but
he's throwing
93 consistently by these guys good at
batford jacks there a couple of breaking
balls gets a strikeout
first time through the order has gone
really well for griffin jacks two down
back to the top
and anderson 15-game hit streak
getting 403. extend the streak right now
because this is just a seven inning game
he's looking fastball all day right here
he launches this ball
right center field he has done it again
spaghetti all week long and a
one-nothing socks lead
same thing he did yesterday extending
the streak with a home run
engel steals second he's there with two
outs and it changes the focus now of
andrew vaughn
i just got to get a base hit and you
absolutely change
your swing thought plan a little number
right out front of home plate jax fields
it jogs over to first underhand flips
and retires andrew vaughn so on to the
fifth with a one to nothing lead
still a lot of dangerous hitters ahead
lance is not
the prolific strikeout guy today but he
hasn't had to be because he's throwing a
lot of
a lot of pitches in the zone like that
there's a whiff for you yeah he throws
it by him of course if we promo the whip
then he does
i mean that that's what kind of guy he
is only the third strikeout
for lynn danny mindick started second
base the first game
another foul from danny mendick oh great
catch
in the club level just a fantastic play
that's why you bring the glove everybody
should
fist bump lancelin against the two three
and four hitters for minnesota in a
one-run game this is a huge inning right
here
pivotal inning two out sixth inning
nelson cruz
and the o1 pitch a blast to left field
and deep back it goes and
tie game nelson crows finds the white
sox bullpen and left
one swing of the bat it's a 1-1 game in
chicago
and man it comes at a prime prime moment
but now apparel blocks in the bottom of
the seventh
and it's up to tim anderson and his
16-game hit streak against duffy
and the 3-0 he swings and pops it up got
jammed
playable kirloff and foul groud he's got
it and we have more baseball from
chicago and his crew steps in one for
three today
three on one out one one eighth inning
pitch is swinging a broken bat flare
into left field it's gonna be hamilton
over and he'll make the call and catch
it's a broken bat sac fly for nelson
cruz
celestino scores 2-1 twins two
on two out now it's up to polancos we're
gonna line drive into right field that's
a base hit
alright swiping his hand on the plate
before the swipe tag from collins
3-1 twins a brave steps in
hitler's and three trips crushed to left
center field
gordon is not going to get there and
it's one hop over the wall
the sox are within a run at three to two
two down it's up to engel again the 3-2
pitch of swinging a fly ball
into left playable larnick in on the
grass he's calling he's got it and the
twins win the game
3-2 in eight innings